all right let's review some of the um
coverage I guess we would call it
including on Fox News of the firing of
Tucker Carlson some of this stuff is
really funny some of it's kind of sad
some of it's you know a little bit of
both or somewhere in between I'm going
to start with a clip of Harris Faulkner
Harris Faulkner has increasingly been
one of the more notable uh kind of
partisan hacks on Fox News I think is
the term that I would use in a lot of
different ways she devoted 35 seconds to
telling us that Tucker Carlson is no
longer going to be at Fox News she
falsely said that Tucker and fox agreed
to go their separate ways what's funny
about that term is like in a sense
anytime someone's fired the parties have
agreed that they won't work there
anymore in the sense that the person
who's fired doesn't really have a choice
like they leave and they don't show back
up so in that sense they've agreed but
the suggestion that this was Mutual is
of course wrong the funniest part of
this clip though is the delivery it's
almost like it's a eulogy at a funeral
but kind of even even weirder she's
really struggling through this let's
take a look we have some news from
within our Fox Family
Fox news media and Tucker Carlson have
mutually agreed to part ways yeah and
again it's not really mutual insofar as
when you're fired you kind of have to
accept it
Tucker's last show was this past Friday
wow and starting tonight Fox News
tonight will Air live at 8 pm Eastern it
will be an interim show with rotating
Fox News personalities until a new host
is named
we want to thank Tucker Carlson for his
service she's acting like this is going
to be the naming of a new pope you know
I mean and but but you know I'm not
Catholic so it's not like I even really
glorify the naming of a new pope but
when you consider the Pomp and
Circumstance around it she's acting like
at some point so or or the you know the
next uh the next Dalai Lama is going to
be selected as a host and prior to that
as a long-term contributor
wow so really only 31 seconds and then
four seconds of Silence there the the
funniest part is when she said that it
was Mutual for sure there was really
nothing Mutual about it then we go to
Charlie Kirk Charlie Kirk one of the
most I mean I would say prominent and
Powerful right-wing voices when it comes
to indoctrinating college and recently
College age people I think is a fair
um
a praise of sorts of Charlie Kirk he is
talking about Tucker as if Tucker died
almost it's like he just got fired he'll
do his propaganda elsewhere but Charlie
Kirk also sounds like he's eulogizing
Tucker Carlson here
some tech issues here too
Tucker Carlson re-made the right that is
one thing I will agree at The View on he
was more powerful than anybody else
since the death of Rush Limbaugh in
reshaping the rights in moving
the Overton window in pushing forward
positive narratives in challenging
operation Mockingbird
and say this as somebody who knows
Tucker very well he did not care about
the backlash right and he is still alive
I know you might think wow so Tucker
died I guess Tucker is alive he's just
been fired and he will I am sure I am
certain I'm confident he will continue
doing all of those things that Charlie
talked about uh just on a different
network and then the third reaction to
this and this I love this is a message I
can really get behind the third reaction
has been stop watching Fox News we need
listen they fired bongino now they fired
Tucker and Jesse Waters is on paternity
leave which I guess when Pete boot Edge
Edge took paternity leave it was bad but
Jesse Waters can take paternity leave
it's all very strange but the message
that they've been coming up with is it's
time to not watch Fox News anymore that
is a message I can get behind here's
propaganda Steve Bannon suggesting that
approach which actually said hey the
reason to watch Fox you got Maria in the
morning you've got you've got Jesse
right he's getting there but Tucker is
really the reason to watch Fox uh with
this I don't know why anybody needs to
watch anything on the Murdoch Empire
because Tucker was the Mainstay of the
uh the populist voice over uh Fox and
it's just the Blockbuster news uh
Tucker's announced he's leaving and not
just after the last show was fun Tucker
didn't really announce that he's leaving
like even that that's also not true
Tucker hasn't and Tucker on Friday
thought he would be back yesterday
Tucker was fired he's announced that
he's leaving so tonight they're going to
replace it with I don't know Fox News
tonight or something but no Tucker
Carlson at Fox News it looks like no
Tucker Carlson and Fox Nation the
streaming service we'll get more details
of that yeah he's been fired okay so
he's he announced that he's leaving
listen the not watching Fox I mean that
Steve Bannon is known for
political
maneuvering that includes the use of
so-called chaos agents in fact there's
now a report and I I'm not saying that
this is actually completely accurate
it's a report and I haven't looked at it
yet but there's a report that
Bannon has been encouraging Bobby
Kennedy Jr to run against Biden not
because Bannon likes Bobby Kennedy Jr
but as a quote Chaos Agent a really
great Chaos Agent Type move would be
for the right to come out with a
campaign against Fox News that would be
an absolute and total Delight so I'm I'm
behind that stop watching Fox News the
way Steve Bannon says that was the
reaction from some on-air people let's
now look at the reaction at Fox News to
Tucker as firing from staffers